Books are wonderful, aren't they?
There are so many different kinds of books.
Yes, their stories can take us to different places.
Stories can teach us about many things.
This little girl is reading a story with her dad.
They are reading in a special room.
Do you know what this room is called?
You're right, it's a library.
Libraries are filled with all kinds of wonderful books.
There are books for adults and children.
When you want to borrow a book from the library,...
...make sure that you sign it out first.
Many libraries now use automatic computer checkout to sign out your books.
Oh, make sure that you remember to return your books before the due date,...
...or you might have to pay a fine.
What kind of story is this girl reading?
Nice work, it's a Dora the Explorer story.
Which kinds of stories do you like to read?
I like adventure stories.
Learning to read is very important,...
...because reading unlocks the wonder inside a book.